Nasty Foot: I'm a big nasty foot in your house. Guess what, it's your day to clean me, get crackin'!
*Shakes head in disgust*
Markiplier: *Whimpers* Okay
Oh, oh I have a timer
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Ashi Wash
Now this is a game that was made in the Game Jam just recently, and-
*Inhales* (Btw Ashi is Japanese for foot/leg)
It features this giant disembodied floating foot that is awfully bossy
And telling me what to do, and has gross fungus on it and its toenails are horrible
And it's got flies floating around!
And it's not attached to any sort of body
And I-
(Distracted) What is that?
Is that rock candy growing on the back of your heel?
*Laughs* I hope it's candy
Oh God...
So, the idea is that you're supposed to clean this, and...
That's it!
That's *Incoherent laughter* This is about the weirdest spectrum of games that I played
...But
Y' know...
It's not the weirdest!
And I honestly can't say what the weirdest is
It might be Murder Clown if you haven't seen Murder Clown, go see that one
But this, this you take, according to the gameplay that I saw,
Which I did not see much, but I did see,
You're supposed to-
Ah, crap
You're supposed to take this spray can-
Nasty Foot: I swear if you don't move any faster, I'm gonna turn your house into a pile of dust!
Markiplier: NOOO!
I don't know how you're gonna do that, you don't exactly have any other body to go with that,
But I- I guess I shouldn't question the Giant Foot
Is this working? Why is this is not working?
Hell- Oh, there we go, I gotta get closer
So yea, you gotta get rid of the horrible fungus, that's growing, on all the parts of your,
Friendly neighborhood foot here
And then go about your merry-
Your- yer-
(Traumatized gibberish)
Sorry, my brain is-
Nasty Foot: Better hurry up ya shmuck, I'm gettin impatient over here!
Markiplier: Oh, wouldn't want you to get impatient buddy
But,
My brain is still reeling from the fact that I'm playing a game about cleaning a giant disembodied foot
That somehow is talking to me!
If I go to the top there and get a top-down perspective,
I might just gonna see a weird, disembodied mouth blabbering away
Like an asshole
Okay, do I do this too?
Is that what this do, or is that something else?
I'm not gonna get it in time-
Oh,
Hello,
Hi,
Oh,
*Laughing* I love how these are the same textures as the walls
Did I mention that this was made in a Game Jam?
I can only assume...
No? *Clips nails* Oh God, that was it. Oh, God nooo
Ugh
(Still in distress) Oh, nooo
Oh, no, that's so gross
I mean, for SOME people out there, this is probably an amazing game and you all love it very much
Alright, I'm not gonna comment on anyone's personal preferences-
Nasty Foot: You're running out of time!
I don't know what I'm doing... Oh okay
*Laughing* Do I get to wash my eyeballs from seeing these horrible things?
Hey, how do I get that?
I want that! I gotta pick off the rock candy from the-
*Picks up pickaxe* Oh, E, okay, it's E, not click
Well, I'm doing very poorly!
I don't think I'm gonna win and then he's gonna turn my house into dust!
Okay, hang on!
Hang on wait, *Grunting*
Oh, God, oh God, that's some crunch to that munch!
Oh, wow, I could just go right in the foot
Oh no, I can't never mind
Nasty Foot: Ugh, I'm still filthy, now I gotta smash yer house up!
Markiplier: You don't gotta-
Nasty Foot: -Them's the rules
Markiplier: Uh, you made the rules though you could-
Nasty Foot: (Again) I'm a  big nasty foot in your house. Guess what, it's your day to clean me, get crackin'!
Markiplier: (Laughs) You didn't actually do anything!
Oh my God that amazing. Okay, I'm gonna go for the far one first
*Wipes off spit*
Excuse my spit, it's just the spit of jubilation
I'm so happy that my, my, my "career" has devolved into me playing a game,
About me cleaning off a foot!
*Laughs* A giant, maniacal foot that wants to destroy my house
Who invited him anyway?!
I, I, I failed to mention that I have a certain number of questions about this arrangement in the first place,
And I don't exactly know (crunching rock candy) Oh good, it's randomly generated, it's got infinite replayability
As much as you wanna clean this foot
(More crunching and laughing) You can clean to your heart's content
Oh boy,
Okay, so-
*Struggling to finish off candy* Okay
There's some more up there
(Gibberish)
Oh goddammit
(Yells out diabolical alien phrases)
I know it's in there, I know it's in there
You're not gonna bug me on
(Announces confirmation Earth's untimely destruction)
Okay, fine, I'm just gonna believe you on that one
Okay, that's fine and all, I'm not gonna lose
(Breaking off 'rock candy' and chanting prayers)
There was another one over here- There we go
Okay, so got that
Then we just need... thiiiis
(Struggling to balance)
(Spraying fungus)
(Singsongy) Get that fuuungus
It's a good thing that I have exactly the supplies required to be able to do all this
I'll get that fly...
Just gimme, *Sighs*, gimme a goddamn second to get up this
The gravity is not behaving
(Uses Unrelenting Force)
Woah-pa!
How do I-
I'm doing the thing, aren't I?
(Disappointed) Oh, (Victorious) Oh, there we go, that was a squoosh!
Okay, so almost done!
You're almost prim and pretty!
You're almost prim and ready for the prom!
Ya pretty princess you!
Eh
C'mon, get yer, get yer goddamn toes down here
Ya douche!
(Yelling) Ya douche!
Aaand...
SHAAAABOOSKI
C'mon, shabooski
(Wait, I'm not done yet?)
What?
Are you not done?
You look done!
Nasty Foot: You're running out of time!
Markipier: What are you talking about, you're so perfect!
Oh, you're beautiful, you're big, bulbous and beautiful!
Oh, I love the way your...
Arch..?
(Confused) Goes....
Nasty Foot: Ugh, I'm still filthy,
Markiplier: What are you talking about?!
Nasty Foot: Now I gotta smash yer house up!
Markiplier: What?!
Nasty Foot: Them's the rules
Markiplier: YOU'RE PERFECT
You're perfect just the way you are!
(Interrupting Nasty Foot) How about, you're a dick and I hate you?
That's also options for things that you are
(Sudden Tarzan screaming)
(More noises the machine can't pick up)
(Squish)
Bam, there we go
(Might as well give up and use auto-generate)
Awwww
Aw, goddamn it I missed a fly
(Swatting noises(?))
(Interrupting swatting) Nasty Foot: Better hurry up ya shmuck, I'm gettin impatient over here
Markiplier: (Mocking)
Fuck you, man
*Clipping* Okay, there we go
*Spraying fungus* Nasty Foot: You're running outta time!
I got it
(Spraying...Possible freestyling too?)
Nasty Foot: (Finally satisfied) You did alright kid,
Markiplier: Yea!
Nasty Foot: I haven't felt this fresh in years
Markiplier: YEA
WOOOOOO
(Game crashes) Oh, goddammit, it just closed right outta there
So there is Ashi Wash!
What an experience!
A life-changing game if ever there was one
I am-
Weird, and I feel dirty, (Cues outro) and I feel odd
But I'm done with that, so there you go!
You can see the other bizarre games
(Don't)
I've got quite a few, I think there's actually a playlist dedicated to 'em
In the description below or in the annotations over there
So thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always, I will see you,
In the next video
Buh Bye!!!
Top Episode: Why does that make you happy?!
*Screaming* Uh oh
Wa Boop?(?)
(Blood splatters) Ohhh
Bottom Episode: *Laughing* What's happening?
*Screaming*
Why am I recording this? I don't even know...
(Outro fades)